Let's go next to our caller from the seven
oh two area code. Who's calling today from
seven oh two.
Hi, this is Christian. Uh, is this me on there?
Yes it is. And are we on Speaker Phone or
Bluetooth? Christian.
Oh, you were, but now you're on headset. I
love it. Awesome. So, uh, I know you've got
a lot of callers, I'll make it quick, but
it is somewhat substantive. Um, been a fan
for 10 years. I'm curious on your take on
some, uh, policies I've recently re-explore
it and kind of changed my mind on, I've always
considered myself kind of a, I hate labels,
so I don't even like the word moderate cause
it implies that the truth is in the middle.
[inaudible] what would you them I tried to
avoid extremes, right? And, uh, recently I've
come to the realization that a lot of preconceived
beliefs that I would think I wouldn't like
I'm hyper liberal and love politics even I
I think had been victim of a lot of propaganda
and information campaigns or disinformation
campaigns. And uh, I'm curious if you've ever
thought about nationalizing, uh, natural resources
much like Norway does to their oil. Cause
I was thinking about oil in America for example,
is ran by a handful of families, right? And
in countries like Norway, the country actually
profits directly from selling the oil itself
with no middleman. And you know, business
who in business likes middlemen and is kind
of a strange concept to think about. I mean
we're already talking about healthcare, right?
We're going to talk already talking about
education. Why aren't natural resources being
added to the just the discussion because the
oil is like a trillion dollar plus industry.
Well, I think more than just the size of the
industry. I've thought about it because so
what's the argument right now for making the
Internet a public utility? The argument is
that the Internet is so fundamental to every
aspect of almost everyone's lives, that the
idea of making it a saleable product for profits
starts to become problematic. And I think
that would be the reason I think we should
get off of fossil fuels. But to the extent
that every aspect of what we do relies on
them, why are we allowing for profit corporations
to take advantage of that? Now, the only problem
with that is often, so the argument that a
pro business center rightest would make is,
hold on a second. It was for profit companies
that took the initial risk financially and
often it's more than just a financial risk
to establish the systems to harvest the oil.
Therefore, it would be wrong for the government
to just come in and take them over. And I'm
not completely, uh, I mean there is some logic
to that argument, but that doesn't, yeah,
to some degree, to some degree,
like [inaudible] the subsidies that we employ,
essentially, it's like these pharmaceutical
companies are taxed. Like I've looked into
it. Even the Bush family, the CIA gave George
was sick. Well, he didn't. So it's like, to
some degree, yes, there's going to be,
wait, what happened to see, I woke at George
Bush. What, what did, what did the CA give
George Bush?
Oh, the CIA gave George a, the Bush family.
Their oil start. Okay. Well, because he was
so invested in the CIA career was oh yeah.
Oh, it's a, uh, I watched a documentary on
it. But, um, the point of all of that is to
say, I know that individuals are still going
to be, so we'll take you on muskie man. Right.
But people criticize Tesla cause it was birthed
through subsidy. But the reality of course
is everybody wished they could get a $5 billion
subsidy from the government. Not Everybody's
qualified too. So that doesn't take away from
the credit of the achievement of starting
the company to some degree when we're talking
about the product, uh, the property of the
country itself, because Tesla is not the car,
the Tesla and the products that produces are
not the property of the country just because
they gave them a subsidy.
No, and it's not a resource in the same way
that oil is here. Right,
exactly. Right. And I'm with you off of fossil
fuels as long term ideally, but it's still
a huge portion of not just our economy of
international economy and like you said, it
just doesn't make sense to me that these people
profit. The pharmaceuticals are the most insane
example of that, of course. Because literally
we're funding the research development start
to tail end and then at the end of it they
go, okay, now we're going to rip you off that.
That's ludicrous.
Particularly when a lot of the people doing
the research went to public school and they
rely on the justice system and law enforcement
to enforce contracts and make sure no one
steals their stuff. But yeah, I mean listen,
from a practical perspective, Christian, we're
going to get off of fossil fuels sooner than
we nationalize oil. So I think that we should
just put, put the focus on that at this point.
Well, well and not to take them with time.
I'm curious cause it is very radical, right.
That's part of why, and this is, I don't mean
to take up too much time, but I met g curious
about your thoughts on it. So I had a discussion
with a friend. Long Story Short, a lot of
people are really feeling uh, yeah. Uh, Andrew
Yang because he seems like a young ideas driven
guy who's less wrapped up in the politics
of it. I actually, to be honest, if I'm being
frank, I kind of lean towards the Yang cause
they seems a little more savvy.
Okay.
Hello?
Okay. That was weird. Well listen, yeah, I
mean I don't know. I don't know what to say
about Andrew Yang. I've talked about him before,
but that was weird.